hardly standing by for us um Ali it
looks as though and the Brits that were
missing have sadly died
yeah very sad news uh this incident
happened over 24 hours ago 6 30 a.m
local time and a fire broke out on board
which the pictures the video shows that
far completely engulfed the boat to the
dive boat called the hurricane there
were a number of people on board
um 14 crew members as well uh two good
dive guides and there were 15 britons on
board part of a dive trip they were
playing spent a week on board now the
statement that has been
released on behalf of scuba travel
that's the organization that was
organizing this says at the time that
the fire broke out 12 divers were
participating in a briefing on board
while those missing had apparently
decided not to dive that morning so you
know I think we can conclude they were
Elsewhere on the boat perhapsley perhaps
below deck the statement goes on to say
this with great regret that we as tour
operator with heavy hearts must accept
that three of our much valued dive
guests who had not participated in the
dive briefing died on the morning of
June 11th perished in the tragic
accident the boat is being towed back to
an unnamed Port but it is still hot and
smoldering so it's going to take some
time the survivors who were rescued by
an inflatable rib boat and taken to
safety they've been taken to the port I
think of hadada in Egypt they're being
looked after by consulate officers from
the British Embassy up in Cairo and they
will be able to travel back home to the
UK as soon as possible but the
conclusion there of what is a clearly a
very tragic incident that happened at
Sea I think an investigation still going
to see what caused the fire but it looks
to be an electrical malfunction at this
stage okay I was to thank you